[Music]
the killing of George Floyd in Minnesota
has revealed police impunity and the
cheapness of black life in the United
States now the anger and the
condemnation that's followed has been
pretty much universal but despite much
soul-searching across this country how
much is really going to change Anthony
Walker a level student was left with an
axe embedded in his head what drove
Anthony's killers to commit such an
abhorrent act flowers at the scene of
the fatal blow which brought the violent
end to a young life full of promise
why was my brother murdered wah-pah
Dominique Walker whose brother Anthony
was killed in a racist attack in
Liverpool in 2005 what happened to
George Floyd has been particularly
traumatic I'm tired of seeing black
death I'm tired of seeing black pain and
I'm tired of seeing those things and
it's almost being seen as normative and
I'm absolutely tired of it the notion of
not even and him saying I can't believe
it is a perfect euphemism for how a lot
of people feel the events in the United
States are also an opportunity for the
UK to take an unsparing look at racism
on these shores
oh and sources patting ourselves on the
back and saying will we let you come
here and I'm like well no my parents
helped build this country my
grandparents helped build this country
so I am entitled to have space in this
country you know
and as your yeah this this is this is my
home you know even though at times I'm
told that it's not and at times I feel
displaced we need to understand about
racism we need to understand how race
operates in this in this country we need
to understand and how we treat people
better compassion and carnist is in our
core Liverpool like most British cities
still has a problem with discrimination
and the fights for equality in a place
which was once Europe's largest slave
ports is especially acute I experienced
at school where I was called a black
specimen on a day-to-day basis by the
science teacher that was common there
are answers here according to the city's
first black Lord Mayor which can help
the country learn and change when it
comes to race no we're not tolerance I
mean I may have to look at our history
because it's a learned behavior
and it's very firmly embedded deep
seated in terms of everything that we do
so it's about the culture and cycling of
individuals and how we work together
within the black community a time for
discussing enslavement and at apology is
is done you know we need to get on with
the muscle and hand and start
implementing real change
[Music]
the docks have now been redeveloped and
even in these uncertain times attract
large numbers of visitors there are
reminders to of the wealth which helped
the city growth the black lives matter
protests in the toppling of statues is
forcing Britain to reflect on its
history the stories that we tell
ourselves the narratives about how we
arrived at this point we of course all
know about the Tudors the Victorians
plucky little britain and the Dunkirk
spirit but more discomforting chapters
about how Britain accumulated much of
its wealth and having studied more
closely and through a different lens in
Liverpool it said that every brick of
the town is cemented by the blood of an
African and this building really
demonstrates that in the city centre
historian Lawrence west gaff is starting
another slavery tour and the boys are
obviously holding bags which could be
emblematic of the wealth of Africa and
if you look very closely you'll see
bangles or manacles on their legs and
wrists there are secrets everywhere in
the buildings hiding in plain sight
buildings that we walk past and go into
every day monuments and memorials that
we pass or user's landmarks street names
which we use to navigate the city on a
day to day basis all have resonance for
Liverpool's involvement in the trade and
for me that's the reason why I think
they should stay because they're great
educational tools for engaging with a
demographic that you're not going to
find in the standard classroom he says
more and more people are keen to learn a
history of the past which too often goes
untold I think a lot of people are
shocked they don't realize just how
deeply you know our art society's been
shaped by the events that took place in
the 18th and 19th century both here
again and in the Americas where the
enslaved people were transported to
especially a city like Liverpool which I
consider to be probably the greatest
memorial to the slave trade on in
in the country I think people are now
starting to make the correlation between
events that took place along the goal
and the way black people are still
treated in the modern day you know I
don't think you can extricate the
history of the slave of slavery in the
slave trade from the history of modern
racism how it affects black people in
them and in the most visceral forms this
can be seen in many of our magnificent
stately homes beautiful architecture
with ugly foundations I mean in one
sense what you say here the story is
look and all the glitters isn't gold
Henry's got a very dark history but it's
one that we've been facing into for more
than yes the last decade Penryn castle
in Benga was built by a wealthy
industrialist with money made from
slavery in the sugar plantations in the
Caribbean the National Trust is hoping
buildings like this will help provoke a
more honest conversation about the past
there are people out there who say well
actually this shouldn't be there but I
think by by losing it you you you you
lose the story you lose the future of
what can be learned from this when our
children when our grandchildren look
back at this moment in time they look
back at our society what will they judge
us on what would they judge us on having
known and having acted or having known
and having not acted and there are great
swathes of society and great ways of
time when it was still a socially
accepted silence not to talk about the
legacies of this and actually the the
murder of George Floyd has brought that
right to the forefront it has brought
voices out about white privilege about
all of our unconscious bias
[Applause]
[Music]
looking at symbols of racism and
injustice with fresh eyes whether they
are statues or stately homes is
certainly reframing the debate about
racial justice and perhaps it's only
when the past is honestly addressed that
a more equitable and inclusive society
can be built where the color of your
skin is nothing more than the color of
your skin